so we're going to take the uh
shoot on
tesla
okay so he's
he's pushing
your
ground veteran it's very relaxed he can
push he's pushing very very relaxed
so he can stand up you can see he's
really driving
it doesn't matter he can push my chest
it's just you're just ground vectoring
okay he's pushing just ground vectoring
[Music]
so we yield to it don't contest it
we want we do this so he pushes and i
don't let myself get pushed back because
i need the ground path i need the ground
vectoring to generate the internal
aspects of the arc but when he pushes
i don't brace against him anymore okay
once i move into the technique do you
understand
okay so he's pushing and we take the
chewed on
uh
tesla he's pushing you take the chute on
testabaki but we're going to use it
differently we're going to find the
attempt inside here i'm going to change
the timing okay so he's pushing i'll
yield
and my strike will come out
okay he's gonna not play the victim so
he's gonna get his check up there
but it's it's not this
it's it's here he goes to attack it
and the strike comes out okay move your
hand out of the way this is a back
knuckle to the temple
back level to the temple and you're
checking
the other arm at the elbow or above not
below because it's free to do things
so he hits a clue and you hit
[Music]
let's go
so
here i have
what is called open-ended triangles down
below and when i come back up i have
open-ended triangles now at chew down
level
so opening the triangles
give me your hand please
okay
open into triangles
so an open-ended triangle
is
uh i'm going to have about four or five
of them so taylor will come trace them
and you move out of the picture okay and
i'll bring my arms together so you can
see
one
good
this one in front right here
boom boom this one on the other side
over here
boom boom and then there's one more in
the middle here boom boom okay
this is a trapping device
so when i go room
pop
this arm here
is in the trap
i'm going to use this trap
to capture that arm
like a venus fly trap it closes
on the other side of it
not
grabbing it
now you have it trapped
[Music]
now you have it
different
trapped
here i can come this way and use the top
trap
i can come
this way and use the bottom trap
it will depend what he's doing how
sweaty or bloody he is where i'm at but
it's in the trap of the two pinchers
oh
just don't do this
just like in newaza you're taking
control off
it's not going to be there so you have
it
there
okay